salut et bienvenue dans la vidéo numéro
trois sur la résolution des rubik's cube
je vous ai promis lors de la première
vidéo quand cinq formules et moins de
deux minutes vous alliez réussir à faire
un rubik's cube et aujourd'hui on arrive
à la moitié du chemin avec la formule la
plus facile
vidéo numéros unes on a vu comment faire
la face à la première couronne la vidéo
numéro 2 on a vu comment classer des
quatre du centre facile et quand
remplacer les quatre cubes qui sont à
cheval sur deux phases donc la deuxième
couronne
aujourd'hui on va s'intéresser à la
couleur qu'on n'a pas encore utilisé la
6e couleurs on ne sait pas encore
intéressés au jaune
ce pauvre jaune qui a été oublié de ces
vidéos aujourd'hui le jaune c'est ton
jour
notre but à ce stade de l'évolution une
fois qu'on a fini à la deuxième couronne
c'est de créer une croix avec la 6e
couleur donc là une croix jaune donc une
croix jaune dans ce rubik's cube
on a besoin que d'une seule formule pour
sa cdh a inversé h à des soies droite
inversé ou inverser avant inversée au
avant droite
je me mets dans cette position c'est à
dire j'ai les deux couronnes devant moi
la première phase en dessous et celle
qu'on va modifier au dessus des achats
inversée donc droite inversée droite
inversée au inverser avant inversée et
ensuite hachad et donc aux avant droite
au avant droite la première chose qu'on
constate c'est qu'on n'a pas touché aux
deux couronnes et on n'a pas touché à la
première phase et là on a commencé à
ramener du jaune un petit peu au dessus
en se plaçant dans n'importe quelle
position peu importe on va ré appliquer
la même formule d inverser h inversée à
inverser h
à d et là on arrive à un cas très
particulier un cas d'école c'est un cas
qui nous intéresse si on avait eu ça dès
le départ on avait juste eu à faire la
formule une seule fois c'est le fait
d'avoir trois jaunes comme ça en angle
droit
ce qui est génial c'est qu'à partir du
moment où on a cette configuration peu
importe dans quel sens on est on a juste
à le placer ici pour avoir ce début de
croix à appliquer la même formule encore
une fois et là on va avoir la croix
complètement jaune démonstration et
l'angle droit juste ici que je
positionne en haut à gauche
j'aurais applique la formule des indes
car c'est au 1 versé avant inversée aux
avants et droite et je viens deux
positionnées ma croix jaune
le 2e ligne centrale sont bien jaune
elles sont bien positionnées c'est
parfait si j'avais eu cette forme là dès
le départ j'aurais juste à faire la
formule une seule fois et j'aurai
récupéré la croix instantanément
d'ailleurs là dans l'exemple on a fait
trois fois la formule c'est un exemple
volontaires pour que vous me voyez bien
la faire mais c'est rare que vous ayez à
l'appliquer plus de deux fois et et et
bien c'est tout pour aujourd'hui c'est
juste ça il suffit de c'est juste de
savoir ça pour pouvoir faire la formule
des achats inversée hachad et ça permet
d'obtenir la croix en l'appliquant une
fois deux fois trois fois grand maximum
il me reste plus que trois étapes à vous
apprendre des deux formules et vous
serez enfin résoudre un rubik's cube
on approche du but les amis jusqu'à
demain vous pouvez vous entraîner à
casser le rubik's cube en entier pour
refaire la face première couronne
deuxième couronne et lacroix ne reste
plus que huit cuba bien positionné
demain je vous apprends en faire la
moitié 4 sur les huit donc
entraînez-vous bien rendez vous demain à
17 heures pour le prochain mentale
fleuves chao